après deux ans de pandémie sans
rassemblement les inaugurations
officielles d'école se multiplient ce
printemps au centre de service scolaire
de montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 31 mai c'était au tour de ses élèves
dans ahuntsic cartierville de célébrer
leur école primaire louisbourg vient
d'être agrandi
non plus de ce grand gymnase il profite
maintenant de 14 nouvelles classes vitré
dans une aile flambant neuf et coloris
l'école louisbourg peut maintenant
accueillir 150 élèves de plus c'est
vraiment beau les agrandissements pour
moi ça fait ça a fait des émotions
beaucoup d'émotion pourrait dire qu'on
se concentre mieux parce qu'avant on
était vraiment plus serré 25 millions et
demi de dollars ont été consacrés par
québec pour cette école un
investissement parmi bien d'autres
depuis dix ans 89 projet d
agrandissement surtout et quelques
nouvelles constructions ont été lancés
au centre de service scolaire de
montréal près de la moitié sont terminés
on est très content de voir que ça
s'installe graduellement partout sur le
territoire et encore des enjeux mais pas
seulement en terme d' espaces sauf
quelques petits endroits le secteur
griffintown par exemple dont la
population a explosé attend toujours sa
nouvelle école primaire mais d'autres
quartiers comme mercier dans l'est de la
ville ont plus de chance ici on est dans
la durée la pièce centrale de l'école
taurine au deuxième étage puis on peut
voir au plafond le plus du lien qui
permet à la news d'être un très grand
responsable des projets guillaume
geoffroy nous a fait visiter cette
nouvelle école rue hochelaga qui
accueillera en septembre
des élèves de maternelle première et
deuxième année notre intention c'est de
réaliser
une dizaine de projets comme celui-ci
par année la tendance étant si c'est des
étoiles très vite et très lumineuse avec
des espaces communs cette nouvelle
annexe permettra de retirer les huit
classes modulaires installés dans la
cour de l'école sainte louise de
marillac à proximité sur la centaine de
classes placés dans des roulottes par le
cssd m en 2018 ford espace au moins une
vingtaine ne sont plus nécessaires
à montréal la pénurie de locaux est
aussi devenu moins criantes en raison de
la cog vide moins d'immigration exode
vers la banlieue le centre de services
scolaires a perdu deux mille quatre
cents élèves en deux ans ceci étant dit
depuis quelques semaines quelques mois
on voit que la clientèle revient sur
l'île à l'immigration ont repris on
accueille déjà plusieurs centaines
d'élèves par semaine le centre de
service scolaire marguerite bourgeoys
qui couvre lui le territoire ouest de la
ville fait face aux mêmes défis
aucune nouvelle école est prévu ouvrir
l'an prochain mais deux projets seront
inaugurés dont l'agrandissement juste
ici derrière moi de l'école secondaire
paul gérin lajoie dans autrement
les agrandissements sont une bonne
nouvelle mais la vétusté des écoles de
la ville reste un problème qui
influencera aussi la rentrée en trois
ans québec a accordé 5 172 millions de
dollars au centre de service scolaire de
montréal pour des rénovations pendant
une stratégie globale ou un sérum pour
réussir à atteindre notre objectif qui
est actuellement de réhabiliter
l'ensemble des écoles à un niveau de
vétusté en deux sortes 15% on note
autour de 65% aussi je prends la moyenne
globale du parc donc on a deux grand
besoin fatima dans nos écoles à la
rentrée six écoles seront donc fermées
temporairement le temps d'être rénové
les élèves de l'école laurier sur le
plateau mont royal s'apprêtent à
déménager dans villery pour deux ans
c'est cet ancien centre de loisirs
complètement réaménagé qui les
accueillera sa caserne du stress des
soucis c'est
bien mais trop y aura des bleus non j'ai
pas
avoir une école de quartier on n'aura
pas des codes des quartiers pendant deux
ans les aléas du marché de la
construction compliqueront aussi la
rentrée les élèves de l'école primaire
maisonneuve dans l'est pourraient devoir
attendre jusqu'en décembre avant de
réintégrer leur école on voit le c'est
ainsi qu'une augmentation ce terme
débris une difficulté ou si main
d'oeuvre puis on a beaucoup misé à
s'approprier matériaux mais quels que
soient les obstacles
chaque projet terminé est un grand pas
pour le bien-être et la réussite des
élèves et aussi comme à l'école
louisbourg pour leur fierté
[Applaudissements]
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal